justement aujourd'hui alors que la
plupart des villes de france étaient
désertées par leurs habitants cette
journée du 15 août les touristes
débarqués en rangs serrés notamment dans
la capitale où les seuls embouteillages
étaient provoqués par les autocars
massés à proximité des sites les plus
prestigieux
il y avait foule autour de notre dame de
la tour eiffel au pied de l'arc de
triomphe ou dans les salles du musée du
louvre mais justement pour ceux qui
connaissent paris ce mois d'août peut
être l'occasion de sortir des sentiers
battus dans les recoins de la ville on
trouve d'innombrables curiosité que les
guides ne mentionne pas toujours mais
que pierre bergé nous fait découvrir à
travers la caméra de tony laval on a
beau dire les légumes et les fruits du
jardin sont quand même meilleur que ceux
achetés dans le commerce n'est ce pas ma
soeur
ça goûte le ferai cette année les
haricots verts a été bon pour la récolte
le jardinier les avait mis à trois fois
à chaque récolte on a eu au moins trois
à quatre fois pour les 70 à 80 personnes
il le péché aussi comme vous voyez il y
en a beaucoup
disons qu'à sion peut-être pas tellement
tellement sucré mais savoureux
savoureuse et bien parisienne car ce
potager verger nourrit en partie les
prêtres de la maison marie thérèse a une
portée de mousquets de denfert rochereau
ce pari des villages ne se laisse pas
facilement découvrir
on en doute le charme discret est encore
à sharon ou bien à passy dans cette
charmante rue berton ou au pied de la
maison de balzac subsiste l'ancien
bornes entre auteuil et pacy est la plus
vieille maison de paris celle du 3 rue
volta c'est possible mais la plus belle
est sans doute à l'angle de la rue
françois miron et de la rue cloche perth
pour le parisien la montée de la rue
saint-blaise jusqu'à saint germain de
charonne est une des promenades
dominicales les plus agréables qui soit
en outre bien entendu et non loin voici
sans doute la voie la plus étroite de
paris
84 cm de large le passage de la durée
arrêtons nous un instant devant la
maison la plus exigeante de la capitale
39 rue du château d'eau un étage 1 m 31
de façade
ancien sentent des musarde la rue des
cascades est ainsi nommé parce que le
regard saint-martin construite en 16 133
il reconstruit en 1722 recueillait les
autres belles villes jusqu'en 1899
quittant la prison de la roquette
les condamnés à mort faisait ces
quelques pas qui les menait à la
guillotine ils la découvrent est ici
dressé sur cinq pavé large qui existe
toujours ou rue de la croix faut bien
sûr eu coup là le sens d'orsini qui
avait tenté d'assassiner napoléon iii en
1858 de l'anarchiste henry et de bien
d'autres assassins célèbre le premier
modèle de la guillotine avait été essayé
ici en 1792 sur des moutons décapité
près de jeu puis cours de route mais
comment le sait-on
voilà c'est ici
lors des travaux pour l'ouverture de ce
pub en 68
nous avons découvert un puits et dans ce
puits nous avons eues mais des quantités
dose de moutons à notre grande surprise
il n'y avait pas de crâne
il est fort possible que les carcasses
des moutons étaient été transporté après
les essec dans ce puits le plus curieux
cimetière de paris et 112 44 de flandre
c'est là qu'à partir de 1790 contre une
redevance de santé culte pouvait se
faire enterrer les juifs de paris à
condition que leur interne en ce fils de
nuit sans scandale ni appareil en la
matière a coutume et il fallut attendre
napoléon pour que les cimetières
parisiens soit ouvert aux juifs le seul
cimetière paroissial qui est continuer à
subsister à côté de son église est avec
celui du calvaire à montmartre le
cimetière de sharon dans son enclos une
curieuse statut de beg dit le père
magloire qui se prétendait le secrétaire
de robespierre et ne le fut jamais rue
de belleville un vestige unique le
regard de la lanterne tête de l'aqueduc
qui alimentait au xvème siècle
six des onze puis parisien descendons
dans la plaine ou en 1826 mais ce que
véro et d'audace charcutier de l'heure
et à ouvrir une galerie marchande qui
aux nouveautés fut éclairé au gaz
c'était la première
saulieu devint vite à la mode rachel loi
un appartement au dessus de la galerie
où alfred de musset 20 dîner balzac qui
passaient souvent attirés par l'opulente
poitrine de madame vers eux avec c'est
cuit au cem arbres ses boutiques de
collectionneurs la galerie a gardé le
charme discret de la bourgeoisie louis
philippe a et on peut en dire autant de
la galerie vivienne sa contemporaine qui
commet sur une retombée orné de nymphes
et de ds en 1832 l'abbé gazzara y
présentait son invention le cauchemar à
ma sorte de lanterne magique nous on
voyait des paysages derrière des miroir
grossissant donnant l'impression du
relief
en face de la galerie rue radis vide les
étonnants escaliers de la maison qui
abritait un tripot pendant la révolution
ils sont construit de telle sorte que
celui qui descend ne voit pas celui qui
monte et inversement
jadis une cloison isoler chacun de ces
deux escaliers parallèle dont il
n'existe que deux autres exemples en
france et voilà
ni vu ni connu le vendredi 13 juillet
1607 henri iv posait la première pierre
de l'hôpital saint louis
heureusement conservé jusqu'à nos jours
il constitue le plus bel ensemble
architectural du début du règne de louis
xiii
bien qu'il commence selon le mot de
jacques hillairet à être étouffée par de
nombreux agrandissement moderne
en cherchant bien on y découvre le buste
du vert galant et en cherchant encore
mieux un petit bâtiment que l'histoire
rappelle le pavillon de chasse d'henri
iv mais qui ressemble plutôt à une folie
ainsi nommé tonge avis les abris discret
des amoureux fortunés
découvrons enfin un lieu plus austère
l'admirable cloître de l'abbaye de port
royal construit en 1627 par la mère
angélique alors abaisse de port royal
des champs qui fut abandonnée par l as
et religieuses en raison de l'humidité
qui régnait dans la vallée de chevreuse
trois siècles après il sert de lieu de
promenade aux futures mamans des
maternités baudelocque et de port royal